I checked out from news over the weekend
so when I started reviewing events from
the g20 in Japan I had a ton of catching
up to do
we had Trump stepping into North Korea
we had world leaders visibly cringing as
Ivanka Trump tried to talk to them about
policy which I'll get to and then we
also had Donald Trump being asked about
busing and liberalism and being so
clueless that he simply stated that
buses are a primary way of getting
people to school this is one of those
things that is funny in a superficial
sense but it's so so tragic and I guess
I was laughing in order to not cry
because it is the latest world
embarrassment thanks to President Donald
Trump Trump was first asked about busing
as racial integration policy there's a
big history of this in the United States
so when we talk about busing in politics
we're not talking literally about do you
like busses versus vans cars or bikes
for getting kids to school we're talking
about busing programs that date back to
the 1970s the whole point of it was to
desegregate classrooms to have more
racially diverse schools it's very
controversial there are many arguments
to be had about it the reason that it's
back in the news is that in debate one
night - last week on the Democratic side
when Kamala Harris called out Joe Biden
during that debate it was related to Joe
Biden's policy on race related issues
which includes that Joe Biden opposed
federally required busing policy and
Donald Trump was asked about it and the
guy is just so clueless about this that
you can see how confused he is and
eventually he simply sort of white flags
and says buses have been a primary way
of getting children to school clearly
having no idea what Kristen Welker from
NBC News is asking him about and yeah
it's as embarrassing and cringe-worthy
as it sounds let's look at it together
thank you I have a question about the
border but I just wanted to follow up
quickly on the question about busing do
you see it as a viable way of
integrating schools does that relate to
the policy that your husband
something that they've done for a long
period of time I mean you know there
there aren't that many ways you're going
to get people to schools so this is
something that's been done in some cases
it's been done with a hammer
instead of a velvet love and you know
that's part of it but this has been
certainly a thing that's been used over
there I think if if Vice President Biden
had answered the question somewhat
differently it would have been a lot it
would have been a different result
because they really did hit him hard on
that one so but it is certainly a a
primary method of getting people to
schools and is it does it relate to the
policy that you're going to unveil that
you just floated it relates to
everything we're doing and you'll be
hearing about it and over the next
couple of months this is like being
asked about the nuclear triad and saying
well listen triad refers to three and
that's a bigger number than two so
that's really something we have to
contend with I mean it's just idiocy
this is a non-answer and this is what
the President of the United States
believes qualifies as a political answer
to the question then once again during
the same press conference Donald Trump
was asked about Vladimir Putin's recent
comments that western-style liberalism
is obsolete and Trump is so ignorant
that he thought that liberalism meant
those lefties on the California coast
like in San Francisco and Los Angeles he
thought that liberalism meant I guess
progressivism when what we're talking
about here is small-l liberalism which
includes the sort of broader policy
political philosophy of the West that
includes individual rights and
capitalism and freedom of speech and
freedom of religion it applies to most
Western democracies even though it looks
different in Germany and in the UK and
in the United States for example and
those are all small-l liberalism Trump
thinks they're asking about like Bernie
Sanders and he criticizes Los Angeles
and San Francisco I can't believe that
he's the Cygnet but he is thank you miss
to the Financial Times right before
arriving here was that western-style
liberalism is obsolete I know you
probably have read the read well again
he meant
that way I mean he sees what's going on
and I guess if you look at what's
happening in Los Angeles where it's so
sad to look and what's happening in San
Francisco and a couple of other cities
which are a run by an extraordinary
group of liberal people I don't know
what they're thinking but he does see
things that are happening in the United
States that would would probably
preclude him from saying how wonderful
it is at the same time he congratulated
me as every other every other leader of
every country did for what we've done
economically because we probably have
the strongest economy we've ever had and
that's a real positive but I'm very
embarrassed by what I see in some of our
cities where the politicians are either
afraid to do something about it or they
think it's votes or I don't know what
Peter I don't know what they're thinking
but when you look at Los Angeles when
you look at San Francisco when you look
at some of the other cities and not a
lot not a lot but you don't want it to
spread and at a certain point I think
the federal government maybe has to get
involved we can't let that continue to
happen to our cities this is
breathtaking I mean breathtaking
ignorance and Trump puts the cherry on
top with his own closing on this by
saying that he likes the dictators of
the world better than he likes our
Western allies this has nothing to do
with the question it has nothing to do
with what Vladimir Putin is talking
about understand Putin was talking about
our system of government Putin was not
talking about American Privett
progressivism and hipsters in San
Francisco understand the level of
disconnect here Donald Trump thinks that
this press conference was about his
general opinion of kids getting to
school on school buses and he believes
Vladimir Putin criticized American
progressivism like San Francisco
politics in reality Trump was asked
about busing policy for racial
integration and the idea that small-l
liberalism as a political philosophy has
become a sort of obsolete in 2019 Trump
doesn't even know what he was asked
about on with many other presidents I
mean I'm actually struggling to even
talk about this with somebody like
george w bush okay whose policies I
completely disagreed with you would
actually be analyzing what Bush said
mostly along the lines of whether with
whether you agree with it and whether we
believe that he is reaching the correct
or incorrect conclusions on the basis of
the facts that are out there Donald
Trump doesn't know what he was asked
about okay Donald Trump answered
questions that were not asked it is a
total joke of a presidency and
unfortunately too many trumpets are
equally ignorant here they also don't
know what were the questions actually
about small-l liberalism and busing for
racial integration some of them do not
know what it was about some of them also
don't know so they came away from this
thinking trump's on it
Trump knows what he's talking about we
are the laughingstock of the world and
that's actually the theme of the next
story as well a lot of laughingstock
over the weekend today's program is
sponsored in part by zip recruiter i've
talked on the show about how challenging
the hiring process is it's hard to find
qualified candidates it takes a long
time you have to sort through a lot of
often unqualified candidate resumes but
there is one place where you can go
we're hiring is simple fast and smart
and a place where growing businesses can
connect to qualified candidates and
that's zip recruiter dot-com slash
Pakman zip recruiter sends your job to
over 100 of the web's leading job boards
but they don't stop there they're
powerful matching technology will scan
thousands of resumes find people with
the right experience and invite them to
apply to your job as the applications
come in zip recruiter analyzes each one
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match and the zip
recruiter system is so effective that
four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter and get a quality
candidate through the site within the
first twenty four hours and right now
our viewers and listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at the exclusive web
address zip recruiter dot-com slash
Pakman zip recruiter comm slash PA que
ma N one more time that's
zip recruiter dot-com / Pakman